And now the old scout master.
I will, uh, make us all sound incredibly intelligent.
You got your work cut out for you, Clark.
Yeah, every month,
You know, after this whole experience, you know what they say about making sausage and loz. it's just
Yep
The peak behind the curtain. it's quite a show.
Well, we do our best.
Okay, this is podcast number 145..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Last week's trivia question was: we all know Baden Powell held the first scout encampment on Brown Sea Island in 1907.
What was the name of the landowner who allowed scouts to use his property for that encampment?
And I gave you a hint, and the hint was his last name had two a's
And the answer is Charles Van Routt.
In 1907, when Baden Powell was visiting Ireland, he made friends with Mr and Mrs Charles Van Routt
and they invited him to visit their country home on Brown Sea Island.
Now, Baden Powell, as a boy, had sailed in Pool Harbor near Brown Sea with his brothers
and he knew the island and they'd even landed on it before,
And he became convinced that Brown Sea would make the ideal location for his first camping experiment.
It was isolated, but it wasn't too far away from civilization to get provisions,
And so he sent a letter to Charles Van Routt and asked for permission to use the island,
and it produced an immediate response. of course he could,
And the rest is history, as they say.
A number of you went to scoutmastercgcom and submitted your answers.
I got a lot of replies for Charles Van Routt.
I did get a few votes for Major Kenneth McLaren but, sorry, wrong answer.
It wasn't Major Kenneth McLaren.
We'll talk about him another time, shall we?
This week's winner, chosen randomly from amongst the correct answers, is Ann Olson.
So, Ann, I'm going to get an email to you and make sure that you get your prize,
which is a copy of Cliff Jacobson's Camping's Top Secrets,
One of my all-time favorite camping books,
And we'll have a copy of that winging its way to you very soon indeed.
If you joined in all the fun and you ordered a Stuff Adult Leaders Say t-shirt,
I got good news. they're headed to the post office this week.
We finally got them, got them all packed up and getting ready to send them out,
So look for them soon. and we nearly made the deadline,
Which is the middle of November, pretty much,
So I really appreciate it.
That was a lot of fun.
There are no more of those t-shirts available,
So treasure the ones that you get,
because I'm sure they will become a valuable collector's item.
Well, I'm not sure of that at all.
But hey, in this week's podcast we have a Scoutmaster panel discussion.
We have a wonderful guest and a great question,
which is: should I start a Boy Scout troop?
And if I do, what should I be thinking about?
And I know you're anxious to hear that. so let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another Scoutmaster panel discussion.
Joining me is Larry Geiger, down in Vieira, Florida.
How you doing, Larry
Good Hey Clark?
And we've got Tom Gillard in Tallahoma, Tennessee.
Hello, Tom
Hey Clark.
And Walter Underwood's out there in Palo Alto, California.
Howdy
Saw within the past couple of weeks that the Eagle rank merit badges
are going to change over the next year or so.
Have you guys seen that?
I did, I did,
And there's going to be a new alternative for environmental science
called sustainability. Is that right?
That's correct.
Now, I haven't seen any requirements or anything on that.
I don't think they've published too much on it.
Does anybody know any more about it than I do?
I searched for it and it's not giving you anything yet.
And then cooking merit badge is going to be revamped a bit
and become an Eagle-required merit badge.
What's your take on that fellas?
Again, it was an Eagle-required merit badge.
Yes,
It used to be an Eagle-required merit badge.
but now it's going back on the West.
Back in the day when I was in there,
I got mine and it was Eagle-required.
Yeah, back before Tom got his, I got mine.
I don't remember that being required for mine,
but I could have been encouraging the Scouts to do it,
because we cook camp outs and different kinds of things
And I think a lot of people have earned it without trying.
I was our patrol cook.
I cooked all the time, so I'm all for cooking merit badge.
I guess you could call it a suntan merit badge,
because if you're out in a troop that's camping often
and using the patrol system,
you're going to end up cooking quite a bit
and you're going to earn the merit badge.
You're going to end up doing a lot of things
towards the merit badge just in the course
of what you're doing as a Scout.
I like environmental science,
but I'm glad that there's going to be a little expansion there
and maybe an alternative to it.
My only thing is- I don't know if we want to add another
required one.
I think there ought to be about maybe 10,
but that's just my opinion.
Yeah, I can see the kind of inflation
or other reduction of the choices,
but cooking is a pretty basic skill.
That's a great thing.
Being able to do some stuff at home.
it's really up there with personal management,
with those kinds of life skills.
It looks like, well, they're going to redo
the requirements also,
but I was looking at the requirements for right now
and it looks like a little bit of car camping,
a little bit of backpacking
and a little bit of home cooking stuff going on.
so I don't know what they're going to change.
Well, it'll be interesting to see
and I believe they're rolling out the changes to that
and the new sustainability merit badge
at the Jamboree next summer.
Cooking is one of these. that's been pretty consistent
that you've got to do a menu for,
say, three days in three different styles:
backpacking, outdoors, home
And then actually cook for I think it said
two to three or three to four people.
Well, I know when Larry did it,
you had to either grow or kill anything that you cooked.
It was a seven-course meal.
It included a dessert- apple pie made from scratch.
It included biscuits made from scratch,
the main course and vegetables.
I had to create a warm beverage.
I don't remember all the details.
The fire I built burned up the roots
of maybe 14-inch oak tree in the backyard
and it eventually died.
But I cooked all of that on an open fire
in the backyard.
Memories memories.
One of my family remembers that meal
and the tree that eventually died.
a long time ago,
Sustainability's coming out at the Jamboree,
but cooking's coming out January of 14..
So you're googling as we're talking.
No, I just remembered that.
Oh really. Well, good for you.
I don't remember my last name half the time.
You know what guys?
We're very fortunate. this time around
on the panel discussion
We've got a guest
And that is Arlen Ward,
And Arlen is a Cub Master out in Thornton, Colorado.
Welcome to the panel discussion, Arlen.
Well, thank you, Clark.
I was pleased to be able to participate
in a Google Plus Hangout.
Larry, have you ever heard of a Google Plus Hangout?
It's the vast panorama of social media
that I haven't yet experienced.
It was just a discussion
about starting a scout troop,
And I thought this would be an interesting subject
for us to look at.
Have any of you guys- Tom or Larry or Walter,
have you ever actually started a troop?
I started a troop.
I was in troop 705 on Merritt Island for two years
and we were asked to start a new troop,
So 12 of us moved.
I was already Scout Master.
The previous chartered organization
was kind of iffy-
They constantly moved our room around
as a whole bunch of issues-
And so the new organization-
the head of the organization- was an Eagle Scout.
They wanted us to come so I started a new unit.
It was a bit of a challenge right at the beginning
but it was a good thing.
A few years ago Cubs and our then
had crossed over into a troop
and we were having a pretty bad time of it.
There was three or four older Scouts
and the five younger Scouts-
older being up in the 17s, and then
had the 11-year-olds
And I got wind that the Knights of Columbus
wanted to start a troop.
so I went and talked to them
and that was my first mistake.
So we started the troop
with the five that had crossed over.
We just left that troop and started this one.
The troop I was in as a youth
was actually fairly new at our church.
I'm sure my dad helped start that
And my mom started a Cub Scout pack
in Baton Rouge.
I've walked into a wonderful, functioning troop,
so as a leader, I don't have that experience.
I do not either.
So, Arlen, why this question?
Why are you imagining that you're going to threaten
your sanity by starting a Scout troop?
Well, we've got a great group of
first-year weeblers that are just starting to look at troops,
and we have a lot to choose from in our area.
Some of them quite large,
Some of them on the smaller side.
They each have their own personality,
But we have a number of parents
that have expressed an interest and said,
hey, why not start one?
Why not?
And, as you have alluded to
in previous podcasts,
the call of hey, we could start over
and we could do it exactly
as it's supposed to be done.
The whole Norman Rockwell ideal
of what a Scout troop is supposed to be.
that's the first thing that goes into your head.
And then I remember that this is Scouts
and perhaps there's more to it.
Well, and the next step is the little rascal.
so let's make a movie.
What is the first thing that you think about here?
I mean, how do you advise somebody on this?
My first thought was: Arlen said
that there were quite a few troops
And, like here, if you were to start a new troop,
you're competing for the same boys.
There's four troops now
and we really couldn't support another one.
But if you've got a large enough group of boys
to pull from each year,
then maybe it would be okay to do that.
Would the pack that you're currently in
become the feeder pack for the new troop?
Possibly
We become one of the troops
that pulls from that pack.
Our pack sits around 50 to 60 boys generally
and there's a number of other packs in our area.
I don't think there would be too big of a problem
with it being oversaturated.
Being in a relatively urban suburban area,
there's a lot of boys around here for sure.
The problem is troops without packs
sometimes becomes iffy
If you have one troop pulling from three packs
or three troops pulling from one pack.
you kind of get into these little binds.
The second thing that I would say
the most important thing is your charter organization.
Sometimes you kind of fall into that,
but there's a lot of issues there
and how they're going to support you.
For instance, the ideal meeting space
is a room for the scouts
and then a separate room for the adults
in the door or something like that,
but preferably not one big room.
That's just one issue.
There's a lot of others.
but is the head of the organization
and the committee, whatever board,
are they really on board about this thing?
Are they really into having 30 kids
running around every Tuesday night for two hours?
There's a lot of things like that
that you might want to kind of explore
as you get into it.
If you find the right place
and you're establishing an early relationship
up front,
I think is really really key.
So, as far as looking at charter organizations
without having one, that you hear
through the grapevine that they're looking to start
or anything like that,
how do you approach them through
your district executive?
Do you do that from scratch?
Just introduce yourself and say,
hey, I'm thinking about starting a scout troop.
Yes,
A professional scouter may have ideas.
Yeah, I mean, there's some traditional ones.
If you can find somebody there
on one of the church boards
or organization boards
or the head of the organization
that is going to support you,
Because you need a charter organization representative,
that's a member of the organization
and that's the first person
you want to identify if possible.
Haven't I heard that the group
can be its own charter?
It used to be possible
to form a committee of citizens
and charter a unit,
but that is not being done anymore.
The big troop in Palo Alto
is the parents of troop 57.
Now I may be wrong about this.
I know that in my council
they are not interested
in establishing units
without a formal chartering organization
existing in the community.
Our PAC is actually
chartered that way currently.
as concerned parents of group,
We were told by our council
that by recharter next year,
we need to find a charter organization.
Sounds like they're moving away from that.
What I'm hearing from you guys, then,
is a couple of important things.
Does the area support
the idea of a new unit?
I think one of the ways to look at that
is to look at the number of scouts
and, for instance, a given school district,
and see what percentage
of youth are being served in that school district,
and take a look at the national average
and see if it makes sense
and then securing a chartered organization.
It sounds like
you might be able to kill a couple birds
with one stone there. Arlen,
if you guys are going to be looking
for a chartered organization
to sponsor the PAC,
then you've got a pretty good entree
with the possibility of starting a troop as well.
You had mentioned
that the
charter organization rep
was one of the first positions that you needed to fill.
What are some of the other
adult positions
that you would have to be filled
before you really got started?
You have to have somebody to sign the charter-
The pastor or the head of the board
or whatever. Then you have to have a C-O-R,
and I believe it's two committee members
minimum
to start the troop. The only other thing
you need is two adult leaders,
Usually a scout master
and an assistant.
The committee chairman would be the next
real important
adult position. to start with,
I would agree that the committee chair
is a pretty vital position to have filled.
Tom, what about finances
and things like that? Scouting is not cheap
and there's the yearly registration
for the troop and then there's the yearly
registration for the boys.
You will need somebody to be a treasurer.
There's a lot of money flows through.
a little scout troop
Surprised us when, a few years back,
we started looking at
the fact that we were running about
$20,000 or $30,000 a year
through our account.
Right,
That's a troop of
$30,000 to $35,000..
So if you start on this path
and you've got the people to support
you
and the adults in the charter organization
and you have a place to meet,
then you're going to need either some equipment
or there's got to be some other startup costs
that go along with starting a troop right?
Yeah, sort of
You probably need to buy a troop flag,
but I wouldn't get too wrapped around
the handle about something like that.
You know, start off light.
These new Weeblos scouts
that are going to be Boy Scouts
aren't going to be backpacking with Walter's troop.
You got three to six months
at least of just
ironing a few things out,
But don't overdo that.
Don't get too freaked out.
Start your committee thinking about raising some money.
if somebody will donate you a few hundred dollars,
Take that
and then just go with it.
So basically, you can get by
on the cheap
and still have a good time.
because you live in Colorado.
you've probably got warm weather clothes-
I mean cold weather clothes,
Certainly-
Sun glasses,
ten essentials, all that stuff.
Well, guys, I'm going to have to drop off
here in the spirit of cooking
mirrored veg.
I've got some chicken to pan fry
and a charred gratin
to prepare.
Sounds good,
That's charred
C-H-A-R-D,
not C-A-R-R-E-D
or C-H-A-R.
That's the seasoning part.
so,
so confused
Suggestions for the cooking
mirrored veg. I'll be glad to help out.
Thank you, Walter.
I'm sorry it took so long to get everything going.
Glad to be here
and switching over to the stove.
Is there any more to the? if
part of it,
I can imagine going ahead and starting a troop.
that's going to be a pretty challenging thing.
Larry and Tom,
you've both been through that process
in the end because you had to have two or three years
of
stress and difficulty there-
Two or three.
I'm trying to be
optimistic.
Yes, it's definitely been worth
seeing the boys
go from the little shy
kid to
actually being someone that you really
would like to talk to
and has something interesting to say.
but it's really.
they've really become
good citizens and
all the stuff that Scouting promises.
I think it's a great thing.
organizationally,
Arlen, in the overall scheme of things,
the way Scouting grows as a whole
is by building new units
and not just troops go away,
troops come, troops go.
You're very much
if you've got a charter organization
and you've got these kids and parents.
it's a great way to expand the Scouting
program in Colorado.
I think it's a great thing.
So my biggest thing
that holds me back from doing this
is the feeling, hearing the
three to five years and feeling like
you'd be short, changing those first
group of boys that are coming in.
Are they losing anything out of this
experience when
they're starting off in a new troop, as opposed to
having a troop with some older boys around
to help mentor them and show them
what it means to be a scout?
Absolutely not.
Yeah, there's a little bit
of training you're going to have to do
to teach them how to do patrols,
the PLC. that could have been
done by some older Scouts
and there are some advantages
to that on occasion.
but no, these guys are going to have
their own troop and if you do it right,
it's going to be theirs.
and as they grow and begin teaching
the younger kids,
that's when they begin to reap
the benefits: When they're
13,, 14,, 15
and they started a new troop
and they're telling the younger guys about how
this troop is going to be
the troop for this area
and it's going to be a great troop
and they're teaching those younger guys.
actually, they're going to have some advantages
that they wouldn't have
in an existing troop.
They are the first boys
to step foot in this troop
and that will become their troop
and they will always
be more proud of that, because
the legacy of that troop
started with them
and those traditions that they start
with them. The biggest
problem, in my opinion,
is going to be
you guys pulling back.
if you don't have an existing guy,
like Clark, say, or like Tom,
that's been doing this for a long time,
and as the new guys come in
and grab them by the collar
and back them back off to the adult area,
if you guys can have the discipline
to do that,
send your little guys off occasionally
and cross your eyes and pray or whatever.
but if you can do that,
you will be successful.
I don't have any doubt about it.
You don't want it to be We Blows 3-
Yes,
Everybody that has expressed
an interest in this.
I picked up a bunch of copies of the
control method book and I've been giving them out
like Christmas presents
to anybody that thinks that this is
a good idea, because
it's not going to be like our Cub Scout
pack has been, if we're going to do it for sure,
If you've been reading Clark,
you're definitely on the right path
in the right direction.
It will be harder to
do what you're wanting to do to do this,
but it will be rewarding
also, instead of walking into
a troop. that it'll just be.
it will be different, but it will be much
more rewarding.
Yes, you get to invent it,
you and the guys,
and that's cool and it's a lot of fun.
and it never hurts to have the
Rockwell image in your mind all the time
anyway, because that's what
you're striving for. but, like you said,
the reality.
I think the reality is better. to tell you the truth,
I like looking at
Norman Rockwell stuff, but
oh well,
hahaha,
I've often thought
that it would be interesting just to
try this again,
just to start over again.
I think it would probably put some more gray hairs
on my head, but I think
it would probably be a lot of fun.
that's. the big secret of this
is that we get to have
probably more fun than most of the boys do.
Arlen, are you thinking about being Scout Master?
I am. yeah,
that's one possibility.
there's a few other people that might
want the job as too, but
I would not be opposed to doing that.
in 1991
I started Troop 705
on Merritt Island. my committee chairman was Mike
Schoolfield. well, he has four sons
and a daughter, and David is
one of those- is getting married in December.
where I got an invitation to his wedding
he was one of those 12
Scout. those 12, 10 of them made
Eagle Scout. you know we were eventually
grew up to like 50 Scouts
and you know in the Troop meaning 40-50.
right at the beginning
Mike and I bonded.
he was my committee chairman for
six years. it's just been
a great time in my life.
it's a cool thing.
you guys pretty much have me convinced to do it now
sorry.
well, we can say sorry
in a year or so.
what kind of reaction do you get
from the other units? I mean, is it
friendly, supportive,
hostile? your pack
and the troop kind of go to
a place and start together.
they're gonna have a little bit of a hard time griping about that.
otherwise, troops
and they get along fine.
you know, every month you go your own way
and occasionally get together, you know,
but it's not usually a problem.
yeah, since the troop that we
left was so small,
they didn't like it very much because
that sort of put a death sentence
on them. they they survived
for another two or three years and then
they finally folded
because they didn't have, they weren't getting
any of the young boys coming in.
you know, like Larry said, that we like
each other. we see each other at round tables,
we see each other at camperees,
but for the most part we don't see
each other. I would think you probably
are gonna get reactions all over the map
as a scout master of a long
established troop and we're very healthy
and we're in good shape. if somebody started
a troop down the street, I would offer
whatever we could do to help them
succeed. so the more choices that
boys have, the better. it's more
scouts and that's that's always
a good thing. and almost five years ago now-
but I'm gonna mention the name of a town,
Lynchburg. what famous
comes from Lynchburg, Tennessee? they make
soda pop there, don't they? there you go
stout soda pop.
they started a troop
or they reorganized their troop
and they had a very good
relationship with me
and and some of the other
adults in the troop.
they wanted to come to the troop
and be a patrol
in in the troop and they did this
for about
six to nine months
just to see how things
were going before you know they would.
they would come on Monday nights to our
meeting and then they would go have their
meetings on Tuesday nights and we were
sort of their mentor. so
one of the troops that you've got somebody
that you really know and and the troop
is doing well and doing it right.
you might want to talk to them and see if
you can, just to see how things are
are being done.
let me ask you a question: have you talked
to the boys that would
be possible members of this troop- about
the whole idea? we haven't yet
because we didn't know if we wanted
to present that to them as an option.
I am fairly certain
they're a pretty tight group of boys.
they enjoy spending time together.
I'm pretty sure
most of them- if they don't have
older siblings
in another troop,
I would say most of them- are probably
going to go as a group to do
something and if we present them
the option of, hey, you can start a troop
and we can make it whatever you want, exactly
like we've just been talking about,
there's very little doubt in my mind
that they will all stand up together and say:
let's do it.
you say they're wee blows ones.
the thing that you want to do
is you want to organize your troop in September.
you really really really
camping a couple of times and then take them
to summer camp. to do that
you're going to need to start back in September,
October. you and the adults
want to have that first camp out
and summer camp
kind of lined up ahead of time
and get your guys, if they go to camp
that summer,
couple camp outs nearby.
go to a park, set up tents,
make some fires,
go to summer camp.
that September you'll be ready
to start a program year
and take off even without any older
scouts or existing troop.
you'll be set.
so you're thinking about summer camp in 2014,
so next September.
but you want to sit down with this group of parents
who wants to be committee chairman
and you know, here's
what's going to cost to go to camp
and I'd like to take-
if I'm scout master, I'd like to take the guys
to ABC park
February or March for our first camp out.
do you
approach the other packs in the area
and also let them know that this is going on
and they can join you on this adventure.
well, wherever you can get some scouts,
they'll be hearing about it though,
yeah, they'll know.
yeah, I would definitely
make sure everybody knows.
you know the DE is going to be happy as a clam.
you're starting a new unit.
I mentioned it in passing and I think
like it wasn't more than 24 hours
and I was getting phone calls from other people
but it sounded like it was,
it was a done deal,
watch that.
but yeah,
you don't have any Boy Scout experience yet.
I grew up
in scouts,
I went through
Cub Scouts
and became an Eagle Scout.
I've been around the program
and kind of know
how well it worked for me
and kind of what
the overall vision of
scouting is supposed to be,
and I've kind of used that as the metric
for looking at the troops around us.
you're on your way,
yep, yep,
yep. it's a dangerous, dangerous
thing here,
dangerous group of people to talk to.
it's like those roads
out there in Colorado.
but it's, uh, it sounds
like a lot of fun. and you know
I just didn't want to get too carried away with
thinking about the fun parts without
realizing you know
what I was getting myself into.
if you've read Clark,
you know that the secret
is to just keep pulling people in
and as that group grows
it's not that hard.
these folks are going to become your friends.
you know, when you start working together
it's not like
an awful thing,
it's a lot of fun.
it's not too awful,
Clark,
never mind,
it's just slightly awful.
you get to go to the Alps.
come on,
you get to canoe in Canada.
you get to go to Rocky Mountain National Park.
oh yeah, you're already there.
Arlen's bunch can just
put on their packs and walk outside of town.
man, you got a lot of places to go.
man,
uh no, it sounds great
really.
you'll be amazed at how fast those first few years-
and even,
like now for me, 19- have gone by,
because
you are having fun.
something new every week.
did we cover how to handle
youth leadership with a small young troop?
did we talk about that?
that's something that a lot of people are dealing with.
just read what it says
and put them in a room and say:
form patrols and electus
patrol leaders
and don't worry about it too much,
don't freak out about it.
just say, guys, this is how a troop runs.
troops have patrols, named patrol leaders,
and eventually
we'll get a senior patrol leader.
it's really not that hard.
it's a scary sometimes for adults
to kind of do things that way,
but if you just read about
what they're supposed to be doing,
then just try it
and it'll work.
so let me push back at you a little bit, Larry.
so I'm going to take
8,, 10,, 15,, 11 year olds
and I'm going to tell them:
the next step is for you guys to make up patrols,
and then I'm going to actually walk away from that,
and it's not going to be chaotic
and disorganized
and nutty-
absolutely will be,
and not something you probably even want to witness.
see, that's not the picture
that a lot of people have in their minds
about what this is
supposed to look like.
why is that good?
shouldn't we be much more organized?
shouldn't we be a lot less chaotic?
shouldn't we be
standing right there with the boys
so they get it right?
but sooner or later
they have to get the experience,
and they're not going to get the experience
with you standing over them,
they're just going to follow you.
so for them to get the experience,
you have to step back
and let them fail sometimes.
let them get the experience.
well, if you do it,
then it's not done right
because they didn't do it
at that point.
if they do it,
they carry that
in the succeeding years
and they learn.
now you may have to occasionally
clean up a mess,
for whatever reason.
come back and say: guys, are you sure
that's what you wanted to do?
you know,
and like you said, Clark, that's a question.
you ask them: guys,
what did you think about that,
well,
okay. well, what do you think we ought to?
you know, what do you think you ought to do about that?
they'll look at you with blank stares,
and that's the hardest part
is to wait
60 seconds,
because most of us, after 5 seconds, go.
well then that's what you should have done,
and that's the hard.
for most people is the hardest thing
is to wait a minute or two,
and if after 5 minutes,
they have no clue,
sometimes you have to
say: well,
maybe I'll find you a place to go camping
the first time,
but you gotta find the rest of them.
so here's how we do that,
but
you have to let them do it,
even the 11 year olds,
and this will actually work.
one of the questions that you had there,
Arlen, was,
if I did this again, I would do
blank, and I think that
what Larry just said is exactly
what we would probably all
agree: that
in one measure or another, we would
do better now,
given a second chance at it,
stepping back quicker.
yeah,
do you think, Tom,
I definitely would
have-
and, like Larry and you both,
answer a question with a question
to some extent
and keep them thinking
about what it is
they were supposed to have been doing
and what it is they're going to be doing later.
just ask them questions
now, Arlen. there are times-
for instance,
the first ax yard-
no, I don't put 11 year olds
inside the rope and say,
okay, have an ax yard. guys,
wrong, sorry,
that's not going to happen.
they can form patrols
and SPLs,
they can have meetings, but occasionally
you're going to have to step in
and take the guys
that were elected leader or the whole troop,
you know, right off the bat
and say, guys,
you know, this is how we're going to do an ax yard,
okay,
and you're going to tell them a couple of rules.
you know there's a few things
you're going to have to step in.
this is kind of the way scouts do things:
the meetings, setting up an agenda.
you know, give them the form,
let them do it and mess up a couple of times.
all that stuff that they can do.
they can do
and where you draw the line.
you know that's kind of up to you.
you'll have to figure that out.
what you were just saying falls under the safety
safety issues.
you don't want to do that
and suffer the consequences.
what if I try this. okay.
what if we go ahead and we do this
and the boys don't respond?
they'll follow through on things.
is that at that point, do I take over?
well,
there's a fine line again.
scouts go camping.
you know,
if all they want to do is meet for six months,
that's not a scout troop.
say, guys,
this is what an annual plan looks like.
here's the blank calendar.
guys, I'm going to give you an hour
and then see what they come up with
and don't criticize it too much.
they're going to go camping.
you say, guys, there's stuff you got to get done.
now you get Clark.
Clark turns on.
deserve I have a tent. deserve I have a sleeping bag.
how are you going to get there?
you start asking those questions
and see what happens.
and then, hopefully, all this planning
brings in possible troop
meeting activities,
like what's the difference in the sleeping bag,
all these different sleeping bags,
or what's the difference in this?
how do we dig a cat hole?
all this stuff starts
popping up. and now you've got troop meeting
ideas for the guys to plan on.
so it's sort of feeding on itself,
right, and nobody in the troop
knows how to do that.
have an adult come in for five minutes,
show them how to tie a bowling or a square knot,
and then the adult leaves and they teach each other.
if they've all got scout books,
they can figure most of that stuff out.
you know, as a scout master you're going to say:
guys,
you're being turned to page
80 in your scout book. it talks about
your first camp out right there.
okay,
see what you can do, putting together a camp out plan
for your patrol.
I've got to go over and talk to those guys. bye,
Arlen, I'm glad that you could join us
and I hope
we were able to help you out a little bit.
I hope we didn't scare you too bad.
now, this is great information. thanks everybody.
this is wonderful.
Larry down of Air Florida,
thanks again. thanks for your advice.
you're welcome. Clark
and Tom in Tennessee,
have the trees started turning color down there?
they're done,
they're on the ground. the trees are on the ground.
that's serious business.
the leaves are on the ground.
thanks again, Tom. thanks for being with us.
oh, you're welcome. hey, everybody,
have a happy Thanksgiving
music.
hey. well, thanks so much for listening to this edition
of the scout master podcast.
now, before I tell you how to keep in touch, let me tell you
how important it is to hear from you.
this is a conversation, you know, just like we had
in the panel discussion a few minutes ago.
you sent me questions and comments and ideas
and then we respond to them
here on the podcast and on the blog.
but to keep things rolling, we need to hear from you.
so let's find out exactly
how you do that.
you can read the scout master blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog
by email.
the scout master podcast is available on iTunes
and when you go there, please leave a comment
or review a rating. that's always nice.
you can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher smart radio
and you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
you can call in and record a shout out
to be included in a future edition of the scout master podcast
by going to
scoutmastercgcom
and following the shout out link.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right. follow us at scoutmaster blog
on Facebook, tweet scoutmastercg
on Twitter
and you can get into the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle
on google plus.
now, if you're not in the vast panorama,
you can just email me.
that's right, that's sociable, isn't it?
I'm at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
that's scoutmastercg
without any hesitation, I tell you, the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America.
nope, they're not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America either.
hey, it's just me with a microphone
and a laptop and a little spare time,
internet connection, that's all you need.
and we're talking into that microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
so before we leave you, let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and group camping
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everybody.